- So what was going through your mind
when you turned around?
'Cause I didn't really get to
talk to you much after that.
What was going through your
mind, when you turned around
doing your performance and
you were like, wait, what?
- Yeah, I couldn't believe it.
It takes a while to,
to actually
realize that you're not
watching him behind a screen
'cause, I've watched him for
years since I was a child,
- Yeah
- So, to now be like, wait,
this isn't behind any
kind of screen or anything
he's actually here.
- Yeah.
- It took me a while so,
even when I went up to
him, I'm like, what?
What?
- My favorite part was, I love like,
'cause not everybody
you meet in the industry
is, super kind always.
And so I love that you, loved
him since you were a kid
and then you get to meet him
and he's actually really
good and kind dude,
that was my favorite part personally.
And like your excitement,
like your level of joy that
shot from your skin was amazing
and so infectious, it was awesome.
So watching the clip back
on a scale of one to 10,
what would you rate John's dance moves as?
Just saying
- Is he going to watch this?
(laughing)
- Good answer.
Good answer, so you
really mean like a four?
(both laugh)
- I mean for me,
the fact that he was--
- I think he's aware,
I think he's aware.
- He's not that bad, he's not that bad,
I'll give him a six.
- You'll give him a six,
okay, that's nice, that's kind
very PC of you.